the water reaches as far as the eye can
see
submerging villages roads and bridges
the deluge has claimed nearly a thousand
lives in pakistan and affected millions
prompting a government minister to call
it a humanitarian disaster of epic
proportions
we lost our houses we lost our buffalo
we want tents and financial support from
the government our children are sick and
we are drinking dirty water
pakistan has been battered by downpours
since june a month earlier than the
typical start of the monsoon season
the prime minister here visiting those
affected has blamed it on climate change
and his ministers promised government
help
the prime minister has announced that
our top priority is to support flood
victims with financial support first and
will provide funds as much as we can
and funds will be needed to rebuild what
the water had destroyed
like this historic hotel swept away by
the torrent in the northwestern resort
of calum
luckily it was empty at the time but
thousands have been marooned by the
flood water relying on food drops by the
army for survival
and this scarcity of food has caused
outbreaks of illness among children
as monsoon rain started expected
diseases increased especially in
children
gastroenteritis skin diseases and
malaria are most common and one of the
main reasons of these outbreaks is a
shortage of food
pakistan has declared a state of
emergency and asked for international
help
but meanwhile millions of people still
live in misery
milena veselinovich sky news